you mentioned uh we talked about this
article from seeking alpha where the guy
says hey you know
you should sell your amc stocks and then
finally at the bottom he says by the way
i'm short which means he's screwed and
needs you to sell
and you said it was sophisticated
information warfare yes are you familiar
with fourth and fifth generational
warfare
yes so uh a big component being
information manipulation you mentioned
uh the art of war that it's
you want to finish the war before you
get to kinetic you do manipulation
economics
and i'm so i'm just reigniting those
components
as i point to the book you have in front
of you the fourth turning yeah
and we we talked about this with i think
it was ben stewart right yes
the the fourth turning which is i
believe it's strass how generational
theory
which essentially is predicting that we
are about to enter we are entering a
a period of strife the winter season
which could mean a very
we're in it we're in it we're in the
crisis yeah so uh the crisis beginning
beginning of the crisis period we're
past the unraveling
so i will uh i'll just give people a
quick introduction then we'll jump into
it
80 years ago what did we what did we
have what do you mean after world war ii
and the in the
world world war two yeah crisis yes uh
80 years before world war ii
the the civil war eight years before the
american revolution that's right
so because of that people are saying hey
three for three right
what's what's the next big conflict so i
wonder is it is it this internal
conflict in the united states between
the establishment powers which which
does absolutely extend to international
interests for sure but you've got the
culture war here
and then you also have the conflict brew
with china
which is on the horizon taiwan they just
flew 28
warplanes the most ever into the
taiwanese defense zone in the air
and uh what's it going to be is it
neither yeah
can they see that on the camera you
should get and i'll raise it up a little
bit and i recommend everybody read this
book
right just just it's very dense this is
not a beach read
okay this is a very dense book but it is
worth struggling with and working
yourself through it's a real thing to
read books today and not just stuff
online so get that straw somehow
it's it's very uh i i as soon as i heard
about it and got it it and it's been
very
um helpful for me as a framework it's
not perfect like any theory is but it
talks about different generations and
every generation
kind of raises the other differently but
if you look back in american history
from the revolution to the civil war to
the great depression world war ii to
today
it has a certain pattern to it and one
of the things that people particularly
the news business those people i see
that are the
always ahead of the curve understand
pattern recognition
pattern recognition these guys clearly
saw it the um
no i think today i think we're hurtling
towards a couple of crises
one is obviously a global financial
crisis that i think could
make everything else before us uh look
like uh you know child's play
the other there's a massive geopolitical
crisis remember
you go back to classic geopolitics
mckendree right now on the eurasian land
mass
american foreign policy since 1914 is to
make sure that no power or combinations
of power control the eurasian landmass
because the world island which the
western hemisphere is kind of a
island off of the world island the world
island the pivoted that
central asia and those spots control the
world now you have china
with its partners pakistan iran turkey
and russia
right and we kind of forced russia over
that we had every opportunity to break
it off
they are now working almost in concert
right almost with one belt
one road also but everything is focused
around getting off the u.s
dollar getting off the us dollars the
prime reserve currency and the swift
system as the system that ties it
together
they're looking to work in concert and
in their controlling eurasian landmass
will lead us to a
kinetic war in the south china sea or on
the border of india or somewhere
along those fissure points unless we are
wise enough and smart enough to start
acting like a great power along with our
allies
and as long as we continue to act like
children and our leadership act like
children
and to allow the chinese communist party
and in the party at davos
to infiltrate every aspect of capital
markets wall street our global
corporations all of it
you know information warfare and
economic warfare who have every ability
to take this thing down and to do it in
90 days
yet the elites in our country refuse to
do it and it's the little guy this is
the just like in
every other war it's the little guy
that's going to go over there
it's a little guy's kids are going to go
over there they're the ones going to be
buried in foreign battlefields their
taxes the ones that are going to pay for
it
they're going to have the financial
strife and that's why it's time for
populist left and populist right that
are populist and nationalist
to me to transcend politics see where we
agree put this together
realign the politics in this country and
we can control the country for a hundred
years
so uh um i'm curious because uh we had
the american revolution which was an
international conflict essentially
then we had a civil war civil war was an
internal conflict and we had another
external conflict i don't totally agree
with that you don't think so no it was
also part of a remember
lincoln and these guys were also
nationalists obviously slavery drove it
but slavery
drove it let's leave the moral issues
aside which were horrific
it was also the thing of economics and
in in the
exploitation of african-americans for
free labor right
and lincoln these guys were nationalists
they were hardcore nationalists remember
lincoln in his term
uh built the transcontinental railroad
right past the homestead act
which allowed free land and set up the
land grant universities which allowed
the common man's kids actually go and
get an agriculture and technical thing
so these guys were nationals
they had a they had a nationalist
perspective and the southern plantation
aristocracy were part
of a globalized system with the united
kingdom that they're even thinking of
going to brazil
in south america and start a slave
empire down there that would be part of
a global empire
and basically essentially tied back to
the british if they could get around the
thing of hey
we're gonna have slaves drive this just
like the slaves in china remember
the slave labor of china drives the
entire system today we still have
slavery
the slavery in china drives the system
today but what i mean to say is the
fighting was internal
the fighting was here yes then we had
another international conflict overseas
so i wonder if in this fourth turning
are we going to be experiencing an
internal conflict like we had uh the
boston globe reported
yes that uh john podesta said if biden
doesn't win
the west coast should secede from the
union 48 states were involved in this
lawsuit that got thrown out eventually
and so uh i'll put it this way um
we see the stuff with china russia
obviously south china sea is big
we just had russian war games off the
coast of uh 300 miles west of hawaii
freaked everybody out
you've got president biden which many
people are concerned he's not up to
actually defending taiwan or being
commander-in-chief at a time of serious
war
silicon valley west yeah with the chips
we don't have a choice
right right exactly forget the moral
thing you don't defend you think you
gotta slow down and get in your f-100
truck right now or your refrigerator
cause a chip shortage
let's let the ccp take over charlie won
so uh you mentioned
the people who have been successful have
been good at pattern recognition and so
uh
a lot of my success came from my ability
to be at the right place at the right
time during the occupy era during the
vice when i was for vice
i would be like here's the place we need
to be i'd fly there and then boom news
would explode
i'd happen to be there be able to film
it and that's why i got accused of being
a fed half the time because they were
like how does tim know to be in these
places for these big stories it's like
no i just recognized all the news that
was bubbling up and i went and checked
it out
for the past several years i've been i
would say bullish on
some kind of civil war be it the culture
war
culminating to a very serious economic
crisis it's been called a cold civil war
or even a hot crisis between political
factions i think a lot of people
like bill maher for instance he said you
couldn't have this because the
mason-dixon line would go through you
know grandma's kitchen
but that's because he has no
understanding of civil wars
internationally he's
fixed on some american idea where states
fought states and not say spain
where you had regions that just diverted
into you know were dominated by certain
ideologies
so i've had a lot of people tell me i'm
wrong every step of the way
from the start of the street battles
from even occupy water that i
experienced into the battle for berkeley
where you'd antifa proud boys
and it got particularly bad where we're
still seeing some of these battles i
don't know if it'll escalate beyond that
but the the culture war the ideological
rift the wokeness the anti-woke is
is at the highest point of government
it's in the military it's in the federal
government
it's in the presidency it's in the
opposition of the presidency it's in
congress
you've got uh woke policies you know
trainings happening in federal
government and then i still have people
say to me
tim you're wrong there will not be a
civil war could never happen here
and now we're at the point where they're
still saying it and then i mentioned
january 6
like if these people on the left say
tim's crazy for thinking this i
now i just respond with on january 6 a
bunch of right-wing people
stormed into the capital a lot of them
bumbled in mind you the cops opened the
doors
but uh what would you say about that and
then they go quiet i bring all this up
just to see what your thoughts are on
the potential for
you know civil war if that's going to be
our our our fourth turning or if it's
going to be international conflict
i think it's a combination of both and
look on the civil war aspect it doesn't
need to get
it doesn't need to get violent i think
we're in a pre if you go back and study
history
we're in a nastier uh more vitriolic
time than before the civil war go back
and say the 1850s
how long until someone gets caned in
congress well okay this is right here
this is this is my point
and that was pretty of a pretty violent
time right a pretty violent time
and the passions ran very hot
you're in that aspect today but we do
not need to devolve it in fact to me the
suckers play is to try to get violent
this is what i was always against you
don't need the insurrection act
we're winning we're winning the people
in this country are now
awakening to the fact of what the
economic reality is and how they've been
particularly republicans
remember all these world corporations in
the social media corporations
that are shutting down republicans
across the board
the last 30 or 40 years of republican
orthodoxy has been given deregulation
give them tax cuts
the reason i fought the tax cuts
president trump and his tax cuts worked
out very well but certain aspects of
i wanted to tax the wealthy i wouldn't
increase the tax rate to 44 percent
number one i made the starling thing
they don't pay taxes anyway and last
week we saw
you know and merrick garland just
remember joe biden's attorney general
merrick garland says my number one
priority
is to get the leaks of the 25
billionaires
that were put out there and by the way
mitch mcconnell comes out and says it's
my number one priority too mary graham
says this
let's let's but because that story went
down the memory hole
you didn't see story after story in the
new york times about that you didn't see
story after story
and even the conservative media you
didn't see story and story on on on cnbc
right 25 billionaires that have control
of i don't know
500 billion dollars in assets at least
that are reported
right half a trillion dollars 25 over
the last five years
have paid a combination less than 15
billion dollars in taxes
that's what i said raise the upper rate
because they don't pay taxes now
and they can avoid eventually which is
going to be the tax on the assets
because that's going to come somebody's
got to pay for this if we're going to
have this level of spending
you've got three ways to pay for it
either sell the bonds to japan and china
right you either raise taxes or or you
or you print money there's one you could
grow out of it but we're stuck in
in a low growth survey you know
environment because we're so overspent
so now there's 30 trillion dollars you
know obama because of the
what he did to the federal reserve and
the zero inch rate we had a 10 trillion
down obama's watch
and we've added another i think eight
trillion dollar or four trillion two
two or three trillion dollar trumps and
now we just exploded under biden and
it's it's nowhere it's not stopping they
got this modern modernity theory there's
a new theory about it
but hey that's why everybody's running
to crypto right
that's why everybody's running back to
gold and silver that's why people are
prepping i brought some financial times
and every time you pick it up
it's the global apparatus regulatory
apparatus has one focus of mind how do i
crush crypto
how do i make sure how do i make sure
it's not an alternative
store of value like gold and silver are
yep they don't want you to have an
alternative this is the bank of
international settlements out of
out of switzerland basically that's
running that it's also yes that
it's also the central banks it's the
bank of tokyo it's the bank of england
it's the federal reserve they're all
going to regulate it and now
you can't do these just using blockchain
you can't just be private they want to
get into all the
all the checks and balances the ccp is
shutting down all the all the farmers
themselves to make it tougher what they
want to do
is to they see the ability of crypto and
look crypto's not i disagree with
president trump it's not a scam
there's 2.1 trillion dollars of dollars
in the world trading every day
right using because you have to convert
to dollars to do all trades there's 2.1
trillion dollars out there okay every
day doing transactions all the world
i think there's now 2.2 trillion dollars
of crypto
so there are scams in it but it's
clearly an
alternative that it's definitely a
alternative store value and may it may
not feel like that to bitcoin holders
today
when you're down at 30 000 but but you
know it's but
for guys that bought it at five it is
and it's still an alternative when you
look at these other cryptocurrencies
you've got to take your trade
but the central apparatus wants to take
that option away from you again if you a
central authority messing things up
this is not financial advice yep i'm
just saying um if an individual put a
portion of their paycheck into bitcoin
every week like it was a savings account
they would not be upset today
because i bought i bought bitcoin in
november
oh no oh bitcoin fell to 30 000 rg's
imagine if you told someone in november
when it was at thirteen thousand dollars
that it was going to crash to 30 and
people would panic they would laugh and
be like oh buy some right now
i just i i it's to me it's almost like a
savings account here's where
i'll do why does the system when when
you're educated they teach everything
these
public schools etc even the catholic
schools christian schools but the
particularly public schools in any
college
you never learn anything about basic
finances no you never do
they want you to be illiterate of you
have to get in the world think of your
life in your early twenties or thirties
when you're on your own your
everything's about hey i gotta make i
gotta pay the credit card i gotta pay
rent
you're thrown into the world with no
they want you to be
financially illiterate the power of the
ape army
and what people are doing i'm not saying
buy meme stocks and i'm not saying buy
crypto you know what you need to do
it's time now to act like an adult and
say hey guess what everything they're
telling me is a lie
i'm going to go find out for myself i
want to do my own research
i want to sit there and i want i want to
find it i want to learn about this i
have to learn you have to you have to
become
intellectually financially independent
to make your own choice
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you